you don't realize how much your lips do
yes you have absolutely no idea you just
think it's your teeth I feel like that
after I have novocaine at the dentist
that's kind of that's exactly what this
feeling was like you have you're biting
but your lips actually pull the food
into your mouth and I couldn't pull that
way I could just bite
we just heard Tiffany Chen a martial
artist and partner of Robert De Niro
discussing her ongoing struggle with
Bell's Palsy now it started after their
daughter was born back in April Bell's
Palsy is a rare condition affecting
about 40 000 people in this country
every year but pregnant women appear to
be at three times greater risk for bells
especially in their third trimester or
right after giving birth which is what
happened to Tiffany the cause is unknown
with us now is Dr babek Aziza day he's
founder and director of the facial
paralysis Institute and joins us at the
table thank you so much because I know
this is your specialty you got on a red
eye from California and came here this
morning thank you thank you for Tiffany
this was a complete surprise to her that
this could happen after pregnancy but
it's more common than most people know
isn't it I applaud her for speaking out
yeah it happens all the time and uh
patience because they recover most of
the time not all the time you know
they're treated and they go on but it's
a devastating process until the recover
takes place and not everyone recovers
not everyone recovers no about because
she told us that she feels she's been
told that she has another two to three
months
yeah about 80 percent of people go back
to exact normal smile function
activities but about 20 percent of
individuals will develop something
called synchinesis where their facial
movements are disorganized they get
narrowing of the eyes they get
dysfunction of the smile not exactly
like how it was at the beginning but
long-term problems wow how is it treated
how do you go about trying to fix the
issue so initially it's critical to get
treatment right away steroids have been
shown to really reduce the risk of
long-term problems the minute you feel
or see something the minute you see your
face kind of not moving correctly you
got to go to the emergency room really
for Urgent Care so right away right away
because Studies have shown that very
early treatment reduces the long-term
problem the doctors told her that she
probably had fluid buildup so no one
thought you better do something about
this she said the thing that was
life-changing for her was acupuncture
the minute she had her first acup
puncture session she noticed a
difference immediately do doctors not
know she's told fluid buildup yeah not
many doctors are actually experts in
Bell's Palsy number one and number two
she had a unique situation both sides of
her face was paralyzed so as a result
doctors couldn't see a lot of difference
between the two sides so it was very
very difficult to diagnose her and as a
result she got delayed treatment until
she got her MRI and so forth Dale
mentioned acupuncture and of course
there's treatment if you're seen by a
doctor is there anything else you might
recommend
acupuncture actually without electrical
stimulation is fantastic there aren't a
lot of Western studies looking at it but
it's been used for Millennia long term
if patients do not get recovery we've
pioneered surgeries and treatments with
botox Physiotherapy and surgeries that
can actually help patients really
recover as well do you find most women
don't talk about this that they're
suffering in Silence with it huge
because it's embarrassing right and
people go they stop smiling and they get
depressed because smiling really you
know releases endorphins and makes us
happy and when you stop smiling you go
down and go into a major psychosocial
issues Dr Baba Ziza day thank you so
much for joining us thank you flying
right back to Los Angeles no I have one
day in New York
I can't come here and leave right away